bonjour bonjour
mais était ce que vous nous avez préparé
là ça me laisse un peu perplexe moi qui
suis une fille des villes je connais pas
trop ça parce que c'est vrai pas de
revoir beaucoup sage est l'année du
cochon fête du cochon
voilà et chez vous à la campagne dans
les landes tout le monde avec son coach
tout le monde à 200 cochons en tuer le
cochon on faisait des bouder avait la
tête du cochon et on faisait comment va
faire aujourd'hui du pâté de tête
oui ça j'en ai vu dans les magasins mais
évidemment ça ressemble pas à ce qu'ils
vont nous aider mais avant ça se
comprend pas car c'est dans les petites
pensions pas que c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça qu'il ya quelques mois la halle
a déjà été nettoyé
oui là on était le boucher il réfléchira
et toujours la tête en deux c'est plus
facile pour la faire cuire et plans de
garde des dards voilà les dents on
l'aimé part et vous allez chez le
dentiste
c'est la mâchoire du porte département
il a dit et alors là l'intérieur qu'est
ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
après vous avez vous avez tout ce qui
s'appelle de porc le bien sûr été bon
mais bon tout est bon tout est bon dans
les airs et toutes les heures
assez bon les rosiers au conflit cdi
explique moi ça c'est pas du simple
c'est un pied de veau après tout on a
vraiment fait conduire avec avec alors
autrement dit pour nous faire un pâté de
tête de peur que vous avez besoin de
quoi voilà alors il faut du vin blanc il
faut des joutes il faut de poireaux il
faut de persil il faut de l'oignon de
l'échalote d'uther du laurier bien
entendu des carottes et de l'ail
il faut du vinaigre du sel du poivre ça
vient du décor riant briffault il faut
des programmes voilà du pauvre en
graisses il faut des coûts de girofle il
faut bien entendu
une tête de porc est un pied de veau bon
alors on a gardé au boucher de nous la
coupe et dont il a préparé on oublie les
dents et maintenant par quoi allez vous
commencer on va blanchir cette tête
ce qui veut dire eh bien on va la rendre
plus jolie voyez tous ces trucs
sanguinolent là tout ça là on va ça va
être naître blanc comme ce pied de veau
qui a déjà blanchi regarder comment il
voulait nettoyer les oreilles et on
reprend les importent les oreilles et
les narines tout sera nette à l'écouté
de ses toilettes
alors j'ai mis de l'eau là dedans oui je
vais y mettre du gros sel
la voilà birsa les vinaigres
beaucoup ont le faut mettre le holà et
oui oui pas mal oui est arrivée la tête
dedans tout simplement
alors la passion et de morceaux l'a
voulu l'étudier de fer voilà la regarder
la langue pour faire joli là alors on va
mettre comme ça voilà et on va
l'atteindre
et pendant que ça va blanchir oui on va
s'occuper de faire le bouillon un bon
bouillon un bon bouillon abira bouillon
bien corsé est noirci mais c'est à dire
que vous allez mettre quoi dedans et des
membres de légumes qu'on fait de
brouillon de viande même nom
alors on va y mettre d'abord pas de
viande bien beurré pieds de veau
puisqu'il se dessus on va le mettre un
point que le boucher nous l'avait
blanchi cela et où m on va y mettre de
lime et avec la chemise
oui là ça va donner non vandales et non
pelées l'a envahie m 2 des échalotes 3
échalotes bennett moisson beauce
positionne entre des carottes
regardez ce que va parfaitement les
télécoms sans tiers l'oignon on va
impliquer et là des piques et pardon je
me parle mal un peu de plus de girard
fermeté pour que ça va parfois bien le
bon bout sa parfumerie quand vous
rentrez dans une maison quand on vous
fait un bon bouillon à ce que des gens
vont se situer à 3 4 5 et bien là vous y
allé généreusement pour tout dire à fond
et je vais en faire deux pour faire
plaisir et 8 nous dira au niveau arabe
et le programme
voilà après on va mettre des points
qu'elles n'ont quand même pas dans une
fois vos avions sanitaires du laurier du
persil de tous voilà je tout parce que
ce soit dont la part les bars où ils
sont très rares au township de laurier 2
feuilles de lauriers
on a dû perdre est superbe mais des
fleurs c'est bien un tel effet le persil
un petit peu on aurait pu faire un
bouquet mais comme le bouillon c'est pas
pour servir comme du bouillon on va voir
passer
il y avait là et bien je viens voir les
épices là vous avez
misys elle dans le bouillon vous en avez
déjà mis ben non je vais pas aller avec
2 voila voila apres ensuite je vais
préparer l'étape petit truc là c'est
voilà sens et la lorraine coriandre on
va mettre dans cette gaz dans ce marché
des rien de contraire de coriandre
m'embêterait recommandiez légalement à
nous est de voir l'art indh et du poivre
en hiver on va faire un petit noeud
c'est mignon petit fils elle et
chaussons mais qui nous dit il la remet
un joli petit neveu maïté et ça va
donner vos mon père faire et qu'on
pourra récupérer comme ça mais c'est à
dire que les graves vont pas se promener
partout on arrivera tout à la fois c'est
mieux la regardez moi ça si c'est beau
et on met ça là dedans que récupère
avant après alors ensuite vous aviez du
vin nous but vin blanc et du vinaigre
alors vin blanc voilà là un vin de
bordeaux bien sûr comme d'habitude parce
que nous sommes dans la région m voilà
vous ai déduit [ __ ] alors devine être
un petit peu je l'avais tout atout quand
même parce que là si si ces pauvres tout
ça la vienne va bien ce bébé de tous ces
jus de tous ses suites
bon et sans être bon et puis voilà et
maintenant voilà assez blanchi vous
croyez que ça suffit quatre concerts je
préfère regarder déjà eu la chance de
regarder d'al aroui très vite mais bien
sûr la voilà et voilà alors via le peer
2 peer sur le pied de veau et on devra
attendre maintenant que sa cuisine par
vingt trois heures de tam aux moyens et
on regarde à mais pas moins de trois
heures de temps voilà on affame la tête
de peur est cuit mais qu'est ce que vous
allez en faire
eh bien je vais la sorte vous devenez le
plat oui et on va là elle vous paraît
bien comme il faut on est les excellents
en tout cas ça sert baur un superbe a
bien changé d'aspect c'est mamie louise
dire ça regardez ça assez maigre défaite
et tout ça c'est joli ça y est là il ya
les sources et tout parce qu'ils ont il
faut sortir à jour tout ça alors c'est
bon
regardez mon avis il ya là c'est bon
qu'est ce que vous allez en ferme à leur
arrivée la désosser oui et la coupe est
tout simplement tout à coup c'est quoi
comme attendu mais grâce à des jours
très bien sûr ça ce soit quand c'est
bien puis voyez ça surtout seul sort ses
délicieuses qui a regardé ça toute cette
viande et les oreilles vous les utilisez
non non non non non non non alors les
allées fait une autre là on a fait des
oreilles de porc partition du cartilage
les oreilles hollywoodland quelque part
ou pas oui on va la laisser
on l'apprend pas vous voulez dire non on
l'apprend pas parce qu'on a c'est de
vivre comme ça voilà ça y est allé alors
je débutais sont petits les regardaient
de haut mais ça se fait tout seul
regardez ça on va sortir tous les autres
patients copadoz c'est là un homme
vraiment sans beaucoup les jeux vous
avez loupé oui pendant que moi je vais
blanchir et petits légumes
vous voulez dire la verdure la verdure
c'est à dire que vous allez mettre quoi
à blanc voilà les joutes dans de l'eau
salée chaude bien là samedi je vais y
mettre du persil oui et c'est tout oui
il faut que ça blanchissent combien de
temps 2 1 des minutes
le 3 4 minutes par dont l'ancien grammes
seulement
la vraie fini de couper c'est terminé
mais yvan que cette vun à la terrine
alors le bouillon il y avait le pied de
veau mais on sait bien pourquoi il y
avait le petit de parce que ça fait de
l'âge les maladies
alors donc se mouiller or on va les
coulées dans le sens galatée rendez vous
j'ai eu la surprise
ça va vous arriver là oui oui là en veut
mettre un petit peu de gelée de la
persillade que j'ai fait est fait à la
mer et se dire mieux et il ne faut pas
la faire la machine à perdre a écrasé
ses tableaux là alors une ou non cette
cdu perd pied là et j'espère quand même
pas mal à persuader parce que c'est très
gascon la regarde et on va mettre bien
le fort de la viande de la viande
voilà en 18 ans remettre la ligue une
cet allié résulte que vous avez juré que
j'ai préparé
les joues tu vas pas beaucoup de goût
non mais ces trois là vous allez voir
quand on voit la coupe et ça va faire
aujourd'hui c'est plus la pétition alors
regardez voilà on va remettre un petit
peu de gelée au mais la norme il faut
éparpillés petit peu la voilà à face à
faire aller c'est bien la fao l'a béni à
petite bouche fine il faut dire pour
vient de passer enfin oui que la
jeunesse soit bien clair
alors vous savez que cette réserve
interview ce truc dingue parce que et
deurne
là ça coûte comme les trois fois et je
te porte après 35 et là dedans vous fait
vous n'avez 10,4 par ben oui c'est à
dire vous avez les oreilles compris
forcément j'ai envie d'écrire vous
pouvez penser comme ça ensuite vous avez
la langue que vous pouvez faire comme ça
si on va remettre un petit peu plus de
jeunes et là là je la promène de si vous
devez dire oui voila moi je vais la
promener voilà très bien et que sa
petite mousseline là c'est parce qu'il y
en a c'est on va remettre la persillade
et puis s'est terminée par la route vers
le rail la langue vous avez l'oreille
les oreilles les deux oreilles bon vous
préfère ne pas prendre une personne et
pour une fois ci la langue aussi et
ensuite on m'avait dit je crois
sincèrement la cervelle équipe rugueuse
autres là aussi alors regardez notre
crime pour finir qui fait créer la
terrine qui fait quatre menus mais vous
vous rendez compte pour 30 francs et est
maintenant y'a plus qu'à la mettre au
frais alors là il faut la mettre au
moins de 12 heures à votre réfrigérateur
et c'est parfait vous couper en tranches
vous vous régalez la gelée a bien pris
maïté sens paris appétit ce joli regard
d'un temps de vous la rue qu'est ce que
vous en faites maintenant on va se
dérouler alors ça c'est plus grave parce
qu'alors attention ça respire hier un
cadeau décembre perdant je crois bien
revoir la regarder coup là là
ça c'est réussit pas à temps plein air
ça se mange tout nu comme ça va faire il
le petit peu de vinaigrette ou alors on
peut la faire comme on veut oui on peut
la faire avec des cornichons on peut la
faire avec les crapauds aube et nous on
va la faire avec des quatre voies l'on
peut contenir l'eau dure je vois des
oeufs durs oui de la persillade des
câpres ils urinaient grèce 3 des marchés
parce que pour les petits voilà et c'est
tout là alors on va mettre tout ça parce
qu'on va laisser comme ça elle aussi est
un coupé c'est bien mieux parce qu'on
trouve sous la dent bien sûr demeurer
chez les doigts alors sel et poivre
alors on met du sel et du poivre
et c'est là qu'on met la persillade y en
a c'est maïté dents mais pas davantage
les aînés les gars ce n'est qu'après le
vinaigre un petit peu de vinaigre et ça
finit devant le marin et de lui d'
et ça y est regardez maïté s'emparait
délicieux appétissant et je crois qu'il
n'y a plus qu'à souhaiter un bon appétit
à nos amis avec un plan si agréable bien
sûr voilà alors à bientôt
au revoir bon appétit à bientôt
[Musique]